はい皆さんこんにちははじめしゃちょー
です
けんすけさん今日はなんと
北海道の山奥の方へ来ております
若干温度の方はちょっと涼しげな感じには
なってはいるんですけれども見てください
これそして私今どこに来ているかと言い
ますかこちらご覧くださいアイスビレッジ
星野リゾートリゾナーレッドクオリの世界
に来ております
非常に冷え込んでおりましてちょっと寒い
んですけど今回ですねおそらく世界にない
でしょどうやら
氷でできたホテルがアイスビレッジの中に
あるらしいのでちょっと今回そちらに
泊まってみたいと思います当主確定これは
すごい
本当の氷をえこれでできたホテルがあ
るって事でしょちょっと早速中の方行き
たいと思いますすごいねでも見て
交流できてる
そりゃそうかちょっと行ってみたいと思い
ます
めっちゃ綺麗なんだけど
[音楽]
おいすごいなんかまるで呼吸をしているか
のように生命を感じますねこの
イルミネーションからは
性的な意味で
じゃなくて生きるという方のねこのやっぱ
木の感じが北海道っぽいよね
the針葉樹林というかあんまりこんなに
背の低いきってないから
めっちゃ綺麗じゃね足元気をつけてね
結構滑るんすよ当たっても自動でやばい
それちょっとどうしても氷のホテルに
泊まりたくて今日はちょっと健介と俺の
2人で北海道の方に旅行に来てますやっぱ
男旅2人もいいもんだな
イルミネーションの雰囲気がちょっと
変わりましたなんか雪の結晶の模様がよし
よしよしよし
これもついたんじゃないですかすごい
奥の方すごくないライトアップされてる
鎌倉みたいなのがすごいあるはいという
わけでついに氷のホテルに到着しました
果たして
氷でできているホテルどんなものなのか見
てみたいと思いますこちら
[音楽]
ちょっと俺を見ていい
氷だねこれが皆さん
氷のホテルですじゃあちょっと入らせて
いただきます失礼します行こうぜ
気をつけろもう床が早速氷だこれ
階段見てこれ全部氷でできてる
これすごいよこれなんかさほんとさ家のさ
あの通路見たくない
やばい待ってすごい
感動したんだけど今
お邪魔します
すごい
[音楽]
えっ本当にすごいんだけど第一歩踏み込ん
でみたいと思いますいきますよ
やばいやばい
マジで全部氷はいというわけでこれが
氷のホテルですすごいちょっと待って
マッチでテンション上がるこれは
シャンデリア
ちょっと違う語学力を失った多分雪とか氷
でその上にシャンデリアついてるん
でしょうねすごいなちょっと色々見ていき
ましょうドアがまずどうなってるんだろう
これこれ公園に埋め込んでるんだろうね
多分ちゃんと鍵もかけられますね
そしてご覧ください
氷のテーブルそして
氷の椅子ですいやすごいよこういうこと
ですよ冷たいお
尻はねちゃんとファーが置いてあるのでお
尻で冷たくないんですけど当たる
膝と手も全部みたいです冷たいとかでも
どうでもいいぐらいテンション上がるな
これあと床が本当にやばい
[音楽]
本当に結構しっかりやばいこれなんだろう
ねお化粧ルームみたいな感じかな
あーここは
ケチ冷たいわ持って1分ですね
[音楽]
どうなってんのこれ
ちょっと押してみてねあしっかり消える
あこれちゃんと家として機能してますわ
これえすごくねマジでそしてここが多分
ベッドですね
ちゃんとホテルとして機能させるためにさ
大事なものだけはちゃんとしてるの偉いよ
ねこういう感じで夜は寝るっぽいですね
えっとねー
このままでは多分無理靴履こうとしたらさ
靴買っちゃうんだけど
そして見てくださいあそこに冷蔵庫があり
ます
確かに
氷が保たれるって事はさ
[音楽]
凍ってますね見えるかな
下の中で冷凍庫なのかなやっぱお酒は凍ら
ないので上が冷蔵庫で下が冷凍ですねいや
すごいねこれそしてまだそこにはなんと
氷でできたソファーがありますちょっと
座ってみますねこれはローテーブルついて
んだホテルなマジで
男はストレートただただ
氷で作ったってわけじゃなくてすごい
細かいところまで作られてるのがマジで
すごいと思います
ちょっと待って
おっはじめさん待ってましたよどこで待っ
とんねん細いっすよ
怖い怖い怖いちょっと待って
怖い
いやいや
何でいいの何いるんですかちょっと
偶然たまたま触雨が氷になってるの
ソファーの下に挟まってたので3人で
せっかくホールドホテルもすごいけど
ちょっともすごいからちょっと
遊びに行こうぜすごいいやこわかっこ
ちょっとこっちに出ない食べる場所がある
らしいので行ってみたいと思います行こう
ぜ
外出るとさ
室内より寒いわ風がある分すごい
氷のロードすごい
ここが今日ケンスケの宿舎か
マジで雪山で遭難した時用のやつほらで
待ってあったかいんだけど
ちゃんとあったかい部屋も準備されてるん
ですね
寒さに耐えれない人はこっちに避難も
できる
遅すぎるぞここがディナー会場ですかここ
が出ない解除です
[音楽]
今まで経験のしたことないようなね食事
ですねありがとうございます
これがメニューなるほど何も見えない
普通のメニューあっても売れちゃうから
透明なのが多分こだわり
はいありがとうございますちょっと
たっぷりかな
本当にね
[音楽]
今音聞いた
ちょっと待ってね
これすらも氷と
全部凍ってる
いただきます
[音楽]
[笑い]
ごちそうさまでした
美味しかった料理までも氷だったね
ちょっとまた色々
氷のなんかすごい
施設というか場所があるみたいなのでそこ
も回っていきたいと思いますいくぜ
何かありました
はいというわけでこちらが氷のバーです
全部これでできてるのかなちょっと入って
みたいと思いますすげえ
そっち絶対入っちゃダメでしょすごい全部
氷にカウンターも後ろも
店員さんも
ヒトヒトヒトこれグラスも氷ですかすごい
[音楽]
なんとまだありますなんとですね
氷でできたコンビニがあるらしいです
これもうねコンビニマニアからすると是非
とも行ってみたかった
想像できないんですよコンビニが氷ででき
てるって大丈夫北海道で有名なセイコー
マートというコンビニがあるんですけども
それがセイコーマート小売店さん
あるある
看板もさぁ
氷でできたよ
氷のセイコーマートです
[音楽]
すげー
こんばんは
すごいコンビニやすごいよそれもありまし
たあの食べるアイスピードインスペーサー
あるけどレジも氷でできてるよすごい見て
もうラインナップが北海道っぽい
[音楽]
この水凍ってますね基本的に
凍ってる297円
最初忘れちゃった
バカバカバカそろそろ寒いですね氷の
ホテルに戻りましょうか戻っても寒いん
だった
[音楽]
というわけでなんと
氷の
露天風呂があるらしいよね早速入ってみ
たいと思います
[音楽]
極寒の北海道の山奥
木々の隙間から垣間見れば
熱々の氷の露天風呂ライトアップされた
湯船と氷のハーモニーを存分にお楽しみ
あれ
入らせていただきます
[音楽]
氷のホテルに戻って寝るんですけどあそこ
2名しか出れないらしくて朝起こしに来て
もらっていいちょっと俺たちの体調がどう
なってるかもわかんないから
ちょっと明日
頼んでくださいホテルに戻りますでは
また明日お疲れ様です
ようやく2人気になりましたね
はいというわけで早速塗っていこうと思い
ます最後の晩餐になる可能性もなくはない
この寝袋マイナス30度ぐらいまで持つ
らしいんで多分大丈夫だと思いますそうと
あったかいはずいただきます
[音楽]
シャボン玉とか持ってくるかなはいという
わけでですねご飯も食べたということで
そろそろ寝ようと思いますもう気づいたら
24時間
寝ましょうはいというわけで寝ますお
やすみなさい
今すごい音したここに硬すぎてマジで
やばい
おやすみ
[音楽]
間違えた
おはようございます
[音楽]
大丈夫ですかいや
めっちゃあったかい
[音楽]
全然寝れました手袋が超暖かいから全然
快適に仕事ができました
[拍手]
[音楽]
さて
死んでる
[音楽]